un des problèmes les plus préoccupants à
paris celui de la circulation pour
circuler il faut effectivement pouvoir
rouler il faut aussi pouvoir s'arrêter
il faut pouvoir avoir des parkings les
pouvoirs de paris le préfet de paris le
préfet de police ont déjà mis au point
certaines mesures des parkings des
souterrains ils ont élargi des voies
rétrécies des trottoirs
mais d'ores et déjà les pouvoirs publics
sont en train de préparer de nouvelles
mesures pour connaître ces mesures nous
avons mené une enquête
voulez-vous la suivre
pour faciliter la circulation dans le
centre de paris en particulier dans les
quartiers d'affaires
les pouvoirs publics étudient
actuellement la possibilité d'interdire
totalement la circulation des
automobiles en recommandant aux
automobilistes l'utilisation des
bicyclettes
mais que pensent les parisiens de ce
projet entendu parler de ce projet oui
oui
personnellement j'ai fait du vélo dans
mon plus jeune âge j'étais à la cvb donc
dans ces conditions je pense que on peut
quand même appuyer sur les pédales
malheureusement c'est on est arrivé à un
siècle les gens n'aiment pas faire un
effort on a personnellement moi je
préfère la voiture pour la bicyclette
site est faut pédaler
vous avez déjà fait la bicyclette oh oui
oui j'en fais avec plaisir si avait pas
tant de voitures
si vous êtes contre ce projet absolument
c'est un retour pour moi de 50 ans en
arrière
comprenez la bicyclette c'est fini c'est
fini et que là où je suis c'est crise
non non vous est favorable à ce projet
moi je suis tout à fait pour je suis
tout à fait pour c'est un instrument
très pratique je pense que pour une
femme c'est l'idéal pour aller chez son
coiffeur pour les autres ce petit cours
pouvaient absolument plus circuler place
vendôme pouvait pu stationner avec une
bicyclette très très facile
monsieur que vous êtes ou quoi en un
projet qui consiste à réserver certains
quartiers à usage des cyclistes oui j'ai
entendu parler de ce projet d'ailleurs
j'ai déjà commencé à racheter une
bicyclette dépit je m'exerce le matin et
le soir je rentrais chez moi du gunner
chemin et qui est sédentaire je
travaille dans un bureau
donc ça me fait en mai de prendre
l'exercice merci je voulais santé au
travail merci à non je suis très surpris
et que pensez vous de ce projet
part je n'en pense rien c'est mais pour
l'instant je trouve que c'est assez
marrant parce que vous rendez compte
remplacer les voitures pour les
bicyclettes
en plus de ça les mini jupes très
intéressant pour nous l'ancien on vous
demande justement d'utiliser
prochainement la bicyclette qu'est ce
que vous ferez que je le ferai face à
gré puis quand vous portez je vois une
religion puisque sera pas gênant pour
vous non parce que c'est une jupe
culotte
j'assure fait des cycles est je ne sais
pas quand
ben mosbah excellent parce que nous
allons voir 3 millions de véhicules dans
peu d'années
évidemment ça résoudrait le problème de
circulation ça soit pas mal tous avait
devant nous ça nous arrangerait bien ça
arrangerait tout le monde j'en crois ce
à décongestionner un peu la circulation
permettra de mieux circuler pour vous
oui d'accord ça pour ça oui
pierrot je crois que vous avez été
séduit par ce projet finalement à tout à
fait séduit et voyez vous pouvez le
constater je me suis mis je suis ce
projet parce que c'est une chose très
importante et il faudrait que tous les
camarades de l'actualité télévisée fasse
la même chose les rues de paris serait
ainsi dégarni on roule beaucoup plus
vite et pour le sport
quels progrès et bien l'appel de pierre
roubaud a déjà été entendu et dès cet
après midi une équipe de l'actualité
télévisée partaient un reportage à
bicyclette bonsoir
la franche comté est la première zone
boisée de france depuis quelques mois
les arbres de notre région souffrent des
pluies acides provoquées notamment par
l'industrie mais aussi par la
circulation automobile
on parle de plus en plus de pots
catalytiques de filtres pour cheminées
d'usiné une mesure toute récente vient
d'être prise elle sera applicable à
partir du week-end prochain déjà utilisé
en grèce et en italie la circulation des
voitures privées
un week-end sur deux
les forêts vosgiennes les franc
comtoises summer au banc des accusés les
plus acides cette pollution a déjà causé
de nombreux dégâts dans d'autres pays
industralisés comme l'allemagne
mais c'est en grèce et en italie que des
mesures énergiques ont été prises pour
limiter les dégâts avec notamment les
pots catalytiques
mais surtout l'interdiction d'utiliser
une voiture particulière un week-end sur
deux pour la première fois en franche
comté et dans les vosges
cette mesure sera appliquée dès le
week-end prochain c'est la plaque
minéralogique de votre véhicule qui
servira de repère une semaine ce seront
les numéros pairs qui pourront partir en
week-end
la semaine suivante les numéros impairs
un ensemble de mesures qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité chez les usagers
normal
pas du tout ces scandales
c'est trop a cependant mal pourquoi vous
trouvez que c'est normal faut s'habituer
ces produits uniquement à limiter la
pollution est ce qu'on pensait que chez
nous en suisse
vous êtes suisse et se seraient déjà en
suisse non pas encore mais on a une
situation en disant que tu as interdite
le dimanche de rouler on s'est habitué
aussi à cette situation la faute
peut-être faire une fois les c'est
pourquoi pas telle matière de droit la
france
non pas du tout complètement
inadmissible
ça me dérange pas remarqué j'ai pas de
perdre la semaine prochaine j'en ai eu
de la semaine d'après donc avec un peu
de chance
si ça tombe bien ça devrait aller enfin
ça me dérange pas est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal pour les musées la
pollution ah ben non non je celui qui
veut rouler le week-end mon jeu je
trouve ça tout à fait normal qu'ils
roulent le week end
voilà
complètement aberrant
ap des montagnes 0,2
surtout quand on est dans le droit
toupet l'assurance de la vignette on
paye déjà les sens assez cher
[Musique]
franchement on
ce n'est ni chine ça c'est drôle italie
et en grèce
pour écouter venez pas me raconter des
conneries s'il vous plaît mais moi je
suis en france je travaille je suis ici
depuis cinq ans je m'excuse je suis venu
ici bosser je n'ai amené pas du tout ce
genre d'histoire parce que on a déjà
fait l'essai en italie en italie
supermarché je vois pas pourquoi dans un
pays comme la france un pays qui
souhaite qui sait kiev soit disant
civilisés par camille des régionales
je ne paie pas de m je n'ai pas ne peut
pas mettre notre région servira donc de
test national n'oubliez pas ce week-end
les voitures avec un numéro impair ne
devront pas roulé la police a déjà reçu
des directives
ce geste fumer une cigarette
vous ne pourrez plus le faire en toute
liberté monsieur jean conrad le ralph
nader français explique la décision que
vient de prendre le ministère de la
santé publique
un bon ministre après consultation
naturellement avec le gouvernement et
avec le ministre de l'environnement a
décidé la suppression de la licence que
constituait la possibilité de fumer dans
les lieux publics
désormais tous les français devront s'y
conformer
qu'entendez vous par les lieux publics
le l'expréssion même temps c'est clair
on n'est ce pas tous les lieux où
d'autres personnes se trouvent en même
temps que vous vous vous seul fumée ou
d'autres personnes peuvent ne pas
comment dirais-je tolérer la fumée et a
fortiori ne pas subir la position que
vous leur infliger croyez vous que cette
mesure sera facile à terapeak
certainement pas chacun sait que le
français très individualiste qu'il croit
beaucoup à ses droits et plus à ses
devoirs mais nous pensons que la
pollution atteint un tel degré n'est ce
pas que tous les français comprendront
que leurs intérêts se trouve dans
l'obéissance ou disons aux conseils
éclairés du gouvernement on estime que
60 % des français sont fumeurs petits ou
gros or une étude du royal college de
londres montre qu'à 35 ans un gros
fumeur environ deux paquets de
cigarettes par jour à 4 fois plus de
chances de mourir dans les dix ans à
venir cas non fumeurs ce fumeur trop
souvent ils empoisonnent le non fumeur
il n'aura plus loin de le faire
l'interdiction de fumer dans tous les
lieux où se tiennent des réunions
professionnelles de plus de quatre
personnes
par exemple la conférence de rédaction
de 24 heures sur la deux l'interdiction
de fumer dans les ascenseurs d'immeubles
privés ou publics
interdiction de fumer dans les halls de
gare dans les couloirs du métro dans les
expositions interdiction de fumer dans
les magasins chez tous les commerçants
dans les cafés
aussi bien aux terrasses qu'à
l'intérieur interdiction de fumer dans
les jardins publics
et puis et surtout dans la rue ce qui
provoque quelques réactions monsieur
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
interdiction de fumer dans une vidéo
publiée en moi je trouve que c'est
normal ça marche ou pas fumeur mais ça
le gêne énormément trappe je quelqu'un
côté le moal la porte s'ouvre la fenêtre
j'ai tout le temps la fumée dans les
yeux comme paragraphe ça c'est une très
bonne chose j'ai appris ça ce matin et
c'est très bien
c'est une atteinte directe à la liberté
individuelle et jusqu'à seulement contre
j'ai envie de fumer je fais un doigt oui
mais vous ne pensez pas que ça peut
gêner les gens dans la rue on a voulu
bien aux fumées les voitures pourquoi
voudrais quoi ce matin la radio ouï
c'est la radio j'ai entendu parler de ça
effectivement c'est peut-être votre
chose car nous dans nos magasins moi
j'ai une petite boutique c'est vraiment
intenable et dans les cachots et
pourquoi
pour ne pas gêner les autres
consommateurs ceux qui n'aiment pas
l'humidité qui change de décembre c'est
une bonne chose
pourquoi parce que les hommes en général
ce ne sont pas très galant et ils nous
envoient des coûts fait de fumer dans
les yeux et vous êtes leur cigarette
partout c'est très déplaisant ne fut
marathon plus ce n'est pas l'avis de la
régie française des tabacs la production
de la régie française des tabacs ne sera
pas affecté par cette nouvelle loi car
il est évident qu'on ne pourra pas
empêcher les vrais fumeurs de fumer une
cigarette dans la rue et notre part nous
avons l'avantagé la régie d'avoir un
service de recherche qui vient de mettre
une cigarette au point complètement
inoffensive et anti pollution qui ne
produira pas de fumer tous les cigares
est intéressante elle sur le marché haut
dans six mois à peu près et nous
détruirons 1,6 est ce dieu principe qui
est ne dira pas de feu sont fumés la
propos de réformes continuons puisque
nous sommes en plein dedans vous
souvenez il ya de cela quelques temps
nous vous avions parlé d'une réforme des
transports urbains avec il était notre
invité sur ce plateau le présidente de
la ratp en effet la ratp souhaite
rouvrir en particulier à paris ce sera
peut-être le cas aussi dans d'autres
grandes villes souhaitent rouvrir des
lignes de tramway et ce matin michel
chevalet à paris première inauguration
d'une ligne de tramway alors que
d'autres sont en préparation en france
et en particulier en province
je veux trop donc le haut un du
boulevard garibaldi à paris vous voyez
là il y a la voix derrière nous il ya la
motrice du tramway
quand on fait aujourd'hui disons
l'inauguration puisque dans quelques
instants devant la presse devant de
nombreuses paul et bien on va couper
symboliquement le ruban tricolore
vous découvrirez donc cette note rédigée
à côté de moi monsieur philippe essig
directeur général de la ratp
donc c'est même un événement important
on remet le tramway en service dans
paris
oui et c'est un événement d'autant plus
important qu'il marque le 125e
anniversaire du premier tramway qu'à
circuler dans paris tiré par des chevaux
voilà donc ce matériel la ré figure
celui qui seront servis cela il s'agit
donc d'un matériel disons classique
oui nous avons voulu mettre en service
cette ligne le plus rapidement possible
aussi nous avons repris notre vieux
matériel celui là était construit en
mais vous constatez qu'il a quand même
bonne allure et il marque hier encore
très bien
mais entre temps nous avons mis en
fabrication les nouveaux matériels qui
seront mis en circulation sur cette
ligne dans quelques temps alors regardez
bien yves mourousi en avant-première
voyez nos confrères s'ouvre largement à
l'événement la vie du rail vous montrez
nous envoyer la vie dure à la merci la
vie du rail vous montre donc le tramway
qui est actuellement en construction
regardez la revue générale des chemins
de fer vous montre ici également une
maquette et voilà vous découvrez ce que
sera ce tramway parisien construit par
alstom
le tramway standards français c'est
exactement monsieur cycle le même que
celui de nantes qui circuleront
exactement et puis alors quelque temps
après c'est celui qui circulera
également sur cette ligne de ma commode
voilà et regardez il est actuellement en
construction à la rochelle chez alstom
là où on construit des voitures corail
et les rames du tgv voilà donc ce que
sera le tramway français qui circulera
donc en france un nombre peut-être
bientôt
grenoble sera close to lose est ici sur
cette ligne non j'ai à côté de moi on va
revenir donc sur la politique de la ratp
c'est vous qui allez dès que le ruban va
être coupé en direct c'est vous qui
allez produire ce premier tramway
vous êtes conducteurs du métro le
conducteur du métro mais c'est un grand
jour pour moi je n'aurais jamais ça vous
changera pas
damas est rien vous avez session merci
dites moi monsieur ici quelques actions
les autres projets de la ratp en matière
de travaux et ça paraît curieux cabrel
autobus le chemin de fer qu'elle met
trouche bunker souterrain la ratp 10 le
tramway mais c'est très important pour
nous le travail et nous avons en ce
moment un projet en cours d'étude mais
nous espérons bien qui sera réalisée
rapidement
il devrait relier dans un premier temps
bobigny à saint denis mais nous espérons
ce sera que la première partie d'un
projet plus vaste puisqu'il pourrait
être prolongé à l'ouest jusque vers
nanterre la défense au sud et à l'est
vers fontenay choisi et la prod bernie
ce sera une ligne qui pourrait être en
correspondance avec toutes les lignes de
métro et qui assurera un effet très
structurant sur le développement des
départements limitrophes d'un mot pour
nos amis de province qu'il s'agit de
faire une ligne circulaire que l'air
autour de paris en tramway et non pas en
ne tenant pas un problème au bras de
d'économie d'énergie économie d'énergie
qualité de la vie moins de bruit et
surtout capacité de transport qualité de
leur exploitation alors un petit coup de
sonnette
on va partir maintenant en direct devant
nos caméras vous aller couper un petit
coup de sonnette now
voilà comme au bon vieux temps d'avoir
les dans le coin on y va à l'essai tirer
tirer que l'on tende pour nos temps
forts
voilà voilà elle marche monsieur
philippe essig la marraine marie hélène
vous couper le ruban coupé leur ai dit
voilà et sous les applaudissements nos
amis les studios merci michel chevalet
pour nous avoir fait vivre
l'inauguration de ce nouveau tramway
parisien et de nous avoir donné des
détails sur les plans concernant
l'organisation des transports dans la
région parisienne avec le directeur
général de la ratp
la haute-normandie vient d'être choisie
par les télécoms comme région pilote
pour essayer à nouveau système de
radiotéléphone marché très concurrentiel
où les appareils japonais se taillent
actuellement la part du lion
après une étude très précise sur le
développement potentiel de ce marché les
télécoms propose aujourd'hui à quelque
trente mille privilégié aux normands un
radio téléphone très bon marché que josé
alcala à expérimenter pour nous posséder
un téléphone dans sa voiture de type
portable comme celui ci est un
investissement coûteux 20 à 25 mille
francs l'appareil de plus la
communication est facturée 5 francs
l'unité dès le mois de juin prochain
les japonais vont investir le marché
européen en important des combinés
téléphoniques pour voitures au prix de
900 francs
c'est pour contrer cette invasion que
les télécommunications vont proposer aux
usagers un système imparable à la portée
de toutes les bourses
voici l'appareil proposé par les
télécommunications c'est un répartiteur
de fréquences son prix 250 francs il est
relié à l'auto radio sur la bande fm de
l'autre côté la prise de raccordement
n'importe quel combiné comme celui ci
fait la sphère l'antenne radio transmet
la fréquence jusqu'au relais hertziens
des télécoms de mesnil esnard lequel
renvoie la communication au central
téléphonique qui joue son rôle
normalement
une seule petite restriction les
télécommunications ne pourront attribuer
que 20000 prise en seine-maritime et
10000 dans le département de l'eure
alors vous savez ce qu'il vous reste à
faire car il n'y en aura pas pour tout
le monde
bonsoir cela faisait plus de dix ans que
le tarn attendait son autoroute et bien
c'est aujourd'hui chose acquise entre
albi et toulouse ceci grâce aux
bénéfices dégagés au cours des
opérations de privatisation un
investissement qui va s'élever à 5
milliards de francs
de quoi en l'imaginent le désenclaver
tout un département le reportage de
dominique deluze et de marque des
matériaux à partir de 1991 fini le
calvaire des automobilistes
ceux qui empruntent la route albi
toulouse ils auront leur autoroute une
opération coûteuse rendue possible grâce
au succès des privatisations
jacques chirac l'a dit la société des
autoroutes de france allait être doté de
2 milliards de francs
ça donne la possibilité à monsieur b est
nourri de faire immédiatement 5
milliards d'investissements de plus ça
fait combien de kilomètres d'autres 5
milliards d'investissements ça fait 200
km 200 à 220 kg le ministre
nous avons un ministre de l'équipement
dont il dont il est de la responsabilité
de nous dire où il faudra les mettre
n'est ce pas et bien aujourd'hui les
choix sont faits et d'ailleurs les
travaux ont commencé
l'acce albi toulouse va bénéficier de
ces 200 km d'autoroutes et voilà comme
la distance entre ces deux villes ne
dépassent pas les 100 km la direction de
l'équipement était confronté à un
douloureux dilemme
il y avait deux possibilités une
autoroute à double épaisseur parce
qu'avoir s'allient pour éviter les
réflexions trop fréquentes sur les
autoroutes françaises
et puis votre possibilité que nous avons
retenu deux autoroutes en parallèle pour
faire plus face au traffic de l'an 2000
quelques petits problèmes techniques
les expropriations les échangeurs il n'y
a pas de précédent en europe mais nous
techniciens seront résoudre ce problème
et c'est une façon l'hypothèse que nous
sommes retenus les plans définitifs de
ces deux autoroutes côte à côte ont été
adoptés et voilà la maquette de l'
ouvrage réalisé au 250e bien sûr la
polémique n'a pas tardé
les agriculteurs du tarn victimes
d'expropriation trouve la pilule un peu
amer avec une autoroute je paie déjà à
la moitié de mes tél avec deux
autoroutes je vous dis pas à chaud perte
ou de les faire quoi alors je sais pas
jouer au real passait voiture
cette double autoroute devrait permettre
un désenclavement deux fois plus rapide
du tarn mais aussi faire école en effet
si pour l'une des deux les dépenses
quotidiennes seront financés par le
péage pour l'autre seule la publicité
alimentera les caisses des panneaux
comme ceux ci vont jalonner l'autoroute
certains sont même déjà installés
ce problème c'est peut-être la vitesse
mais pourquoi ne pas envisager de
réduire la vitesse sur cette autoroute à
cause des publicitaires encore des
publicitaires d'un côté une autoroute
rapide et payante de l'autre gratuite
mais lente à partir de 1991
enfin on aura brisé le monopole de la
route
[Musique]